the girag an experience okay so that's
that but in China no I had difficult
situations with the authorities with the
police will try to get bribes no they
were just I was in a sensitive area you
know to get to the source the planning
it took over two years so I need
government support I needed national
park access I needed an a green
Development Foundation which is like an
organization to make me ambassador I to
make me doctor for a year to be able to
get all of this access but when when I
went through the motions of getting
these different organizations on board
that would give me access to the
authorities and allow me to get to the
source it was it was my husband blows my
mind now is really really difficult to
get off the off the ground but we did
that but still we were so close to Tibet
that the Tibetan police would come over
and threaten to you know get rid of us
and the porters and whatnot so that came
is worried thirteen different documents
or stamped or official or signed so I
had to show them that I had to use the
satellite phone call into the Beijing to
users translation I think that one time
they made me delete all of the
information all of the tract information
I needed for Guinness World Record
they made me delete that but I was
backed up because they didn't want to
have me seen walk in this region it was
quite sensitive there it's like but I
was definitely in China and definitely
in qinghai province sensitive household
just because you've got Tibet and you've
got China and they're very close to each
other so I needed to make sure that I
was always in in China sometimes you'd
get the police come on they think that
you were a spy or something
yeah no idea what they thought but it
came as a shock to them they were also
very worried for my safety so there was
that angle as well but they were saying
once they found out was official it was
legit and they apologized that I should
follow me on the the Chinese social
media you know follow the journey so
that was great but after that they did
say we off just you know bringing you in
for protection there's bears there's
wolves we'd lost you know Western all
along so that got tricky and there was
one stage where they they said you need
to be on the other side of the river so
they drove us 14
was back on herself to a bridge dropped
his off on the other side and we had to
do those 40 miles all over again that
was day six into the journey and we were
desperately trying to get off the
mountains and now we just dropped back
for you we had to walk those 40 miles
again no way around it
nightmare [ __ ] so yeah it was really
tricky there's the source around that
area really sensitive and it was just
and then we found that the locals would
call the police as well they would radio
to the next girl to the next girl to the
next girl until eventually there was
cell phone signal and they would call
the police and the police would often
rock up at 2 3 o'clock in the morning
just to attempt at the location bang on
they rocked up like what are you doing
here so we found out that the locals
were amazing very hospitable but they
were worried and they didn't know if
it's in a Western ado do they report it
would there be in trouble if they don't
report it so they did so it came and
pretty much went from mission hang
seater almost mission escape and evade
we had to escape the sensitive region
that we were in but we had to evade the
locals because we realize that it was
them calling the the priests that when
talk about things maybe think that you
were an escaped fugitive right yeah yeah
do you think of a fugitive in America or
the UK is trying to get away yeah what
better way to just jump into the middle
of nowhere and China walk yes I say
essentially or just again quite threat
for your fugitive yeah yeah maybe some
sort of bank robber type guy that's it
that's a guy ritchie movie so you are
avoiding this sensitive area so this is
a sensitive area that's close to the
tibet and chinese border did you
anticipate any of these things
beforehand like did you guys sit down
with the team like we were then did you
say okay this could go wrong that's
wrong how many games did you figure
could go wrong there's so many things
that could have gone wrong that luckily
didn't this was really sketchy just the
yangtze is just known it cuts through a
lot of diversity it's a beautiful stone
in part one of the beautiful places that
I've been but there are sensitivities
there's the the elevation there is the
the wildlife there's the temperatures as
well
[Applause]